trente propositions contrôle effectué
aux talons d'achille du numérique la
désinformation est un fléau que veut
combattre emmanuel macron le sociologue
gérald bronner a été missionné par le
chef de l'état pour proposer des
solutions lancé fin septembre ce projet
ambitieux a vu naître un rapport
modestement intitulé les lumières à
l'ère du numérique des recommandations
élaborées à l'issue de trois mois
d'états des lieux ont donc été présenté
au président est cette semaine le timing
fait forcément parler au moment où les
anti pacs taxé de complotisme sont
pointés du doigt par l'exécutif des
individus vivent dans la même société
mais pas dans le même monde mental
certains mondes mentaux peuvent parfois
aboutir à des actions concrètes comme la
défiance vaccinale ces recommandations
ne vise pas éradiqué mais a limité la
viralité des contenus qui affaiblissent
la démocratie car la liberté d'opinion
reste l'un des fondements de la
démocratie
joliment dit pourtant pour l'élaboration
de ces travaux menés par gérald bronner
ça avait plutôt mal commencé
le sociologue ne sait pas forcément
entouré des meilleurs pour rédiger ce
document
guy vallancien notamment mis en cause
par la pneumologue et lanceuse alerte
irène frachon pour avoir nié la gravité
de la sphère du médicament médiator
l'urologue avait très vite annoncé qu'il
renonçait à participer à ce projet au vu
de la polémique naissante mais ce n'est
pas tout la légitimité de gérald bronner
lui même et pour certains sujette à
caution selon sa fiche wikipédia gérald
bronner le sociologue chargé de conduire
pour macron la mission anti fake news a
été pris deux fois en flagrant délit
deux diffusion de cette news la mise en
place du ministère de la vérité macro
nist commence mal paradoxal quand on est
censé se poser en juge de paix sur un
sujet aussi épineux que la
désinformation mais peu importe la
polémique rapidement étouffées et gérald
bronner et 13 autres chercheurs ont pu
travailler sereinement pour établir
leurs recommandations plusieurs
ressortent d'abord mieux maîtriser les
logiques algorithmique c'est à dire
lutter contre les dangers de la
popularité en ligne de mire les
influenceurs en effet les algorithmes
ont tendance à privilégier les contenus
fournis par les contes les plus suivis
encourager les plateformes à une
modération plus attentif des
influenceurs afin de les responsabiliser
les conséquences des informations
produites ou diffusés par un conte doté
d'une grande visibilité numérique sont
potentiellement plus importante que pour
des comptes de faibles audiences une
idée qui peut s'apparenter à une
certaine forme de censure mais sans la
prononcer l'autre point important
mentionné par ce rapport c'est
l'investissement publicitaire
responsable objectif éviter que la
publicité en ligne deviennent financer
les sites de désinformation ou
complotistes des acteurs comme music
awards a global design formation index
ou stories y ont justement mise au point
des listes répertorions les sites et
éviter et sont cités en exemple sauf que
pour certains d'entre eux la fiabilité
des recommandations semble elle aussi
elle très discutable news brown
notamment dont le comité consultatif
roberge d'aix de la cia de la nsa de
l'otan ou de la maison blanche est
épinglée pour ses pratiques à des fins
commerciales est accusé de labelliser
l'info à sa sauce dans l'esprit des
manuels macron qui dit fox news dit
forcément ingérence étrangère et qui dit
ingérence étrangère dit forcément russie
en tout cas selon le rapport qui veut
mettre en place un dispositif de
coopération entre plateformes
institutions et communauté académique
pour réagir rapidement aux opérations
détectée sauf que l'exemple de la russie
est sans fondement les opérations
d'ingérence menée par la russie lors de
l'élection présidentielle de 2016 ont
complètement pris au dépourvu
l'administration américaine comme les
plateformes et ajouter une couche de
complexité au problème des allégations
pompée directement sur celle des
services de renseignement américains
mais jamais prouvé le kremlin dénonce
d'ailleurs je cite des accusations
absolument infondée la commission
brodeur est une initiative à saluer
certes mais plusieurs recommandations
semble pour le moins controversé chacun
se fera sa propre opinion